WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA GET UNDERWAY HERE
IT'S A.
IT'S.
NINE AM AND.
.
WE DON'T QUITE HAVE A QUORUM.
BUT WE ARE GONNA WERE.
HERE.
FIRST BILL WHICH IS BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
FOR ITEMS ON THE CALENDAR HERE.
THE AGENDA THIS IS THE MAY
SECOND.
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
AND.
.
WERE UP OPERATING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AT THIS POINT
MISTER WOULD PLEASE GO AHEAD
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
LATE ON THE NIGHT OF OCTOBER
EIGHTH LAST YEAR WILDFIRES RAGE
DO NAPA CINNAMON MENDOCINO
COUNTIES.
THE FIRE DESTROYED OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND HOMES INCLUDING OVER
THREE THOUSAND IN THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA LOAN.
THOUSANDS OF MY CONSTITUENTS
LOST THEIR HOMES AND EVERYTHING
THEY OWN IN ONE NIGHT. AND MY
COMMUNITY WAS FOREVER CHANGED.
THE AFTERMATH OF THIS TRAGEDY
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES ARE
FINDING THEMSELVES UNDER
INSURED.
AND STRUGGLING TO REBUILD THEIR
HOMES
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE WHO
LOST THEIR HOMES WILL WIND UP
UNDER INSURED.
THIS UNDER INSURANCE EPIDEMIC IS
DUE IN PART TO SIGNIFICANT SURGE
N DEMAND FOR BUILDING MATERIALS
AND SKILLED LABOR.
PROPERTY OWNERS AND CONTRACTORS
ALIKE REPORT THE COST PER SQUARE
FILLED PUT TO BUILD A HOME IN
SANTA ROSA HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED
SINCE THE FIRES IN OCTOBER.
THERE OUR EXISTING INSURANCE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
HELP CHECK PROPERTY OWNERS WHEN
REBUILDING COSTS SEARCH.
THIS BILL ACID DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO DEVELOP A HOME
INSURANCE FINDER TOOL THAT WILL
HELP PROPERTY OWNERS TO EASILY
IDENTIFY OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
AND TO REQUIRE INSURERS WHO DO
NOT OFFER REFUSED TO OFFER A
FIFTY PERCENT EXTENDED
REPLACEMENT COST POLICY TO
PROVIDE THE PROPERTY OWNER WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS TOOL.
I WANNA THANK THE COMMITTEE THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE INDUSTRY FOR
THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL IT'S BETTER BECAUSE
OF IT. I INTEND TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS THAT THE
THE BORDER CONTINUE THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO REFINE
THE DETAILS OF WHAT WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE HOME INSURANCE
FINDER TOOL. HOW WILL WORK AND
WHAT INSURANCE INSURERS CAN DO
HELP CONSUMERS SEEKING MORE
ROBUST COVERAGE WHILE THE TOOL
IS UNDER CONSTRUCTION?
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
SONOMA COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS PAUL YODER. AND THEN WE
HAVE ALSO ROBERT HAROLD
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE AS WELL FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A GOOD
MORNING PAUL YOU'RE SHUDDERING
THREE.
ACTUALLY BEHALF OF THIS MORNING
WE HAVE THE MINUTES YOU KNOW
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS BUT
REALLY WE HAVE THE ENTIRE NORTH
BAY.
MISTER WOULD SPILL SOME OF THE
OTHER BILLS ARE MOVING THROUGH
THAT.
DE AFFECT INSURANCE.
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT NOT
JUST TO THE NORTH PAVE THE
FRANKLIN ALL YOUR DISTRICTS.
LOOKING FORWARD.
IF YOU HAVE AN ADDED DID THAT
DISASTER VALUE PROBABLY WILL THE
WAY THINGS ARE GOING.
WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE INSURANCE
LAWS INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA VERY
GRATEFUL ASSEMBLY MODE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AND I OR DRIVE OUT
ON THIS BILL.
OTHERS SPEAKERS TO HEAR ON IN
TERMS OF. THIS BILL MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROBERT
CORRAL A DIP BECAUSE HER FOR THE
PART OF INSURANCE.
OF WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
THAT'S THAT PROCESS THAT YOU
FROM A MEMBER NOTED WILL
CONTINUE.
THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS HAS TAKEN A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO TRY TO MAKE
MORE INFORMATION THAT'S USEFUL
TO CONSUMERS AVAILABLE ONLINE SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE THE KINDS OF
VALID COMPARISONS. THAT WIND UP
BEING SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN A DISASTER OF THIS
MAGNITUDE STRIKES WE ARE DRIVE
OUT THINKING GOOD THANK YOU.
OTHER PERSONS HERE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK AGAINST
THIS BILL.
DIDN'T WILL.
WELCOME TO WINNERS.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JOHN
NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS AND
BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA. I JUST
WANT TO INDICATE THAT.
OUR INTEREST IN CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE ON
THIS BILL IT.
ONE OF THE KEY PARTS OF THIS
BILL IS REFERENCING.
CUT HOMEOWNERS TO INDEPENDENT
SHIRTS AGENTS SO. WE APPRECIATE
THE CONFIDENCE.
IN OUR ORGANIZATION AND OUR OUR
FOLKS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING SURE MICKEY
REPRESENTING THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US WE LOOKFORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM
OUGHT TO REFINE THE LANGUAGE.
BUT WE ARE VERY COMFORTABLE
MOVING FORTH THIS MORNING THANK
YOU.
PARKS EGGMAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURERS ASSOCIATION AMERICA
ROTH OVER A COUPLE OF THE BILL
MOVING FORWARD.
KATHERINE HEPBURN AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION LIKE
TACKLE MY COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS
TO GET IT OFF.
CARE COST PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION WE ALSO MARK
COMFORTABLE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH AUTHOR THINKING.
MICHAEL BOHLIN WITH MEDTRONIC
AYE WERE THE LARGEST PRIVATE
NINE HOSPITAL EMPLOYER IN CINEMA
COUNTY WE LOST.
FIFTY TWO OF OUR EMPLOYEES LOST
THEIR HOMES IN THE FIRE WE
SUPPORT THE BILL.
ALRIGHT ANY ERA SO.
THE MORE THE REMARK TWEETERS
THEN.
OTHER CATEGORIES MISTER WOULD.
SO.
TRAINERS THAT OPPOSITION RATE
GREAT. RUN GOOD GOOD.
WERE OPERATING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE MISTER BIGELOW.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR A QUORUM TO
ARRIVE OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR.
GO AHEAD AND I DO AND MAYBE THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT CAN CAN
ANSWER THIS QUESTION BUT ON THAT
PAGE THREE LINE SEVEN TO
THIRTEEN THERE'S THIS LANGUAGE
SHOULD AGENTS HOW DISCLOSE THE
HOME WHERE THE POLICIES FROM
OTHER INSURERS.
AND WITH IT IF I WAS JUST DUMB.
GLANCING READING THAT I THINK
WILL ARE. THE OPPOSITE AGENT
REQUIRE TO TO GIVE INFORMATION
ON A COMPETITOR'S PRODUCT
BECAUSE THAT WOULD SEEM TO BE
ANTI COMPETITIVE IT WOULD SEEM
SEEM STRANGE.
AND SO WHEN SOME CLARIFICATION
ON ON THAT.
GO AHEAD SIR.
I GET. THE THAT AS EVERYBODY
JUST NOTED. THERE IS REFINEMENT
OF FOOT.
ON THE BILL.
THE INTENTION ISN'T REALLY FOR
AGENT NUMBER ONE TO SELL AGED
NUMBER TWOS.
PRODUCT IT'S.
REALLY TO MAKE A REFER ALL.
MY COMPANY CAN'T PROVIDE YOU THE
INSURANCE.
GO TALK TO THOSE GUYS.
MOON THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO AND
AND THAT PROVISION BY THE WAY
SUNSETS IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN
FAVOR OF.
THE FINDER TOOL THAT THE
WITNESSES TESTIFY TO IT IN SO
WITH THAT BECAUSE THE LANGUAGE
HERE IS THE AGENT SHALL. IT'S
NOT SHOULD.
IT'S SHALL AND SO.
THAT PUTS THE AGING KIND OF AN
INTERESTING POSITION IF THEY
DON'T KNOW OF ANOTHER OF IN
OTHER PARTS OF AGAIN HOW DOES
THAT WORK IN PRACTICE. WHAT WE
HEARD FROM THE INDUSTRY THAT
THESE POLICIES EXIST OUT THERE?
THAT IF CONSUMERS WERE ARE
WILLING TO GO OUT AND LOOK FOR
THEM SO WE'RE KIND OF JUST
SAYING OKAY IF THEY EXIST THEN
THEN THEN HELP PEOPLE FIND THOSE
POLICIES.
I AT THE END OF THE DAY.
IN AYE I DO WE DON'T KNOW HOW
THESE HOW A FIFTY PERCENT PLUS
POLICY WOULD BE PRICE BUT THE
OTHER DAY I WOULD THINK THAT.
THAT.
THE COMPANY'S DANTA STAND TO
GAIN ON THIS BY BY HAVING THESE
HAVE THESE PEOPLE INSURED BUT WE
HEARD FROM THE INDUSTRY THAT
THAT THOSE POLICIES EXIST WERE
SO WEIRD. SO THAT'S THE CASE
HELP US FIND THAT IN THAT THAT
LANGUAGE AND THAT'S FINE WHICH
WE'RE WORKING ON WE'VE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT.
.
AND THE I THINK THIS IS THAT
LANGUAGE IS A BRIDGE UNTIL WE
HAVE THIS TOOL THAT WILL ALLOW
THE CONSUMER TO DEFINE IT. BIDED
ON THEIR OWN.
SO YOU'RE STILL NOT GOING TO
WORK WITH THOSE GUYS DIMENSIONAL
I DEFINITELY ARE A WITH A NUMBER
OF THE BILL.
AS WE CAN TEMPLE RIGHT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR POPPED UP.
MR QUITE NOT QUITE YET WE NEED
ONE MORE.
OKAY.
JEFF.
A QUORUM WHILE THE QUORUM IS A.
ARRIVING HERE MISTER FRAZIER HAS
QUESTION.
AND NORMALLY WHEN WE LOOK AT
PUTTING THE BURDEN ON ON A.
DECLARATIONS OF DISCLOSURES WE
PUT ON STATE AGENCIES.
SO SHOULD THE REFERENCE FLOW OF
THE ASIAN BEAT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE.
SO THAT THEY CAN BE THE THE
LISTER OF WHO CAN OR CAN'T
PROVIDE ADEQUATE INSURANCE FOR
THEM WELL THAT'S WHAT THE TOOL
COMES AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
BUILDING THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL DOES IS TO BUILD THE
TOOL. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING IN THE INTERIM TO HELP
THE CONSUMER IS GOING TO THESE I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT WHEN WE DO
TECHNOLOGY THINGS IN THE STATE
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN. QUICKLY.
AND SO IT TAKES A DIFFICULT
TIME TO BUILD THIS YEAH AND
AGAIN PUTTING SHALL.
THE BURDEN ON A BUSINESS OWNER
WHO MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT DEPENDING ON.
THEIR ABILITY YOU KNOW. HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE IS FOR
SELLING?
AND THEN PUTTING IN THIS
RESPONSIBILITY ON THEM ALSO.
IT AND THEY'RE NOT MAKING MONEY
OFF THAT POLICIES GOOD IT DID
AND IT DOES BOTHER ME. SO I I
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE END IN
INDUSTRY.
IN AYE I'M LOOKING AT LOOK AT
FROM MY FOLKS THAT AT THE END IN
MY DISTRICT YOU KNOW.
THEIR PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO WANT
TO BUY EXTENDED COVERAGE AND.
THE INDUSTRY'S HOLD THIS THAT
THERE IT THAT THESE POLICIES
EXIST AND SOME COMPANIES DON'T
OFFER THEM SO SO HELP THESE
PEOPLE FIND WHAT THEY WANT AND
I.
YOU KNOW HERE I AM AGAIN I THINK
THAT UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
AVAILABLE THEN THE DEPARTMENT
TURNS ALSO DOES KNOW THAT
THEY'RE AVAILABLE QUOTE YOU WITH
YOU. YOU'D BE SURPRISED THERE
ARE THERE A LOT OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES SMALLER SMALLER
COMPANIES THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW
EXISTED PRIOR TO THIS FACTOR.
QUITE FRANKLY AND SO ON THE
DOING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
NINE UNDER THE AUSPICES OF BEING
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
INSURANCE AT PARKMAN KNOWS OKAY
SO I MEAN THAT'S ONE SEND THIS
THEY SHOULD BE THE. THE PROVIDER
OF INFORMATION.
IN THE END THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
LOOKING FOR TO SOONER THAN
LATER.
YEP.
IN MISTER HER RAIL ON THAT
POINT DO YOU BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE READY TO.
OFFER THAT SERVICE SAW ON THE.
THE OF THE PREDICTED SCHEDULE
YET MISTER CHAIRMAN AND PARTLY
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THE NUMBER BUT JUST FOR SOME
CONTEXT A NUMBER OF COMPANIES
AFFECT MOST COMPANIES OFFER A
FIFTY PERCENT REPLACEMENT COST.
EXTENSION.
THERE'S A UP RELATIVE HANDFUL
OF THOSE NOTABLE MARKETERS THAT
DOWN.
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING OVER THE PAST NUMBER OF
YEARS UNDER COMMISSIONER JONES
TO BUILD UP THE CAPACITY.
SELECT CONSUMERS LOOK AT WHAT'S
AVAILABLE GENERALLY WITH NO.
IT FOR EXAMPLE AN INSURANCE
COMPANY MAY HAVE A NUMBER OF
PRODUCTS FILED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
AT DIFFERENT LEVELS THIS IS
TRUE IN AUDIT WAS WELL FOR
EXAMPLE AND THERE MAY BE ONE OR
TWO THAT THEY TEND TO SELL MORE
OF. SO BUT WE HAVE THE LISTING
OF ALL THOSE AND SO. THE SHORT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS YET WE DO FEEL LIKE
THAT TIME FRAME IS IS A GOOD ONE
THERE'S SOME. THERE'S LIKE A
PAMPHLET REFERENCE IN HERE THAT
WERE NOT CRAZY ABOUT WE FEEL
LIKE YET BUT WE'RE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH RIGHT THE THAT THE ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT ON
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE ROLE SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
THEN VOTE ON YOUR BILL MISTER
WOULD.
DALY HERE
MAYES.
BIGELOW.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CHEN.
CHIU.
COOLEY FAIR.
UBER.
FRAZIER HERE GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HARPER BUT.
STERN MAYES IF YOU WANNA MAKE
THAT MOTION I I DO I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH ALL THE
LANGUAGE OF YOUR CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH FOLKS IN THERE WASN'T
ANY OPPOSITION I'M A TO THE BILL
AND SO ON THE OF THE BILL.
SIR SECOND.
THERE'S IN MOTION AND SECOND FOR
THIS BILL ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SAY ANYTHING ELSE MISTER WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
A GOOD.
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CABALLERO.
CALDERON. CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON
BY.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE.
NINE ZERO.
MOMENT THAT MR CHAIRED MAKE YOU
VERY WELL DONE MISTER WOOD
BEAUTIFUL.
AND ARE ANY OTHER.
AUTHORS HERE YET.
MR COULDN'T MISTER COOLERS AND
OKAY.
SURE.
HELL KEEP IT OPEN.
OKAY.
MISTER FRAZIER HAS TO GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
I THINK. WE STILL HAVE WE STILL
HAVE A QUORUM SO.
GO AHEAD MR COOLEY ON YOUR BILL.
ALRIGHT.
PORTER RESEARCHER MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FOUR.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE AND I'M ACCEPTING THE
REQUISITE AMENDMENT.
TO MOVE THE PRESUMPTION FROM
CONCLUSIVE TO REBUTTABLE.
THIS BILL SPECIFIES THE TERMS
OF A WRITTEN QUESTION AGREEMENT
BETWEEN AN INSURER.
AND THE BROKER AGENT ARE
PRESUMED TO BE LAWFUL SEPARATE
TO A REBUTTABLE CONSUMPTION OUR
PRESUMPTION AS.
INDICATE WITH THIS AMENDMENT.
OF THIS WILL UPHOLD THE VALIDITY
OF COMMISSION AGREEMENTS ENTERED
INTO BY INSURANCE COMPANIES AND
THEIR BROKERS AND AGENTS.
OF.
AND.
.
JUST A STEPS IS THE RULES FOR
HOW THESE WILL GET EVALUATE THE
FUTURE. AND IN ANY LITIGATION
ARISES.
CRITIC PRESUMPTION A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT THEY'RE VALID.
AND I'M HERE THEY'VE CRISPER
KELLY REPRESENT MERCURY
INSURANCE.
GO AHEAD SAW MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS MCKAY ON BEHALF OF
MERCURY INSURANCE GROUP AND.
JUST WANTED TO REITERATE THAT.
OUR WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
SOMETHING PROACTIVE.
A MERCURY WAS SUBJECT TO A
CHALLENGE ABOUT SEVEN OR EIGHT
YEARS AGO FROM A GROUP OF AGENTS
CONCERNING THEIR COMMISSION
AGREEMENTS.
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WAS AT LEAST ONE OTHER
AGAINST AN INSURER SEVERAL YEARS
AGO IN BOTH INSTANCES INSURERS
ONE AT THE TRIAL COURT LEVEL.
BUT THE EFFORT IS IS TO DO
SOMETHING PROACTIVE NOW WE
WORKED ON THE LANGUAGE THAT IS
CURRENTLY CONTAINED IN THE BILL
WITH THE. A GROUP REPRESENTING
MOST PRODUCERS.
IT IS. YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
SUGGESTED A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION.
OBVIOUSLY THE.
AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED THAT
AMENDMENT
SO I THINK THAT THE.
OPPOSITION THAT WAS DROPPED
ABOUT EIGHTEEN HOURS AGO I
BELIEVE.
RAISING SOME CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE SOMEHOW INOCULATING
OF THESE AGREEMENTS I THINK IS
ON WARRANTED ESPECIALLY WITH A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION.
YOU ARE. A. ANALYSIS AS WELL AS
THE OPPOSITION OF THAT WAS
DROPPED INDICATED THAT THAT THIS
MIGHT APPEAR TO BE IN
DEVELOPMENT.
HOWEVER THIS IS THE LANGUAGE.
WE WORKED ON OF THE LANGUAGE AS
I INDICATED PREVIOUSLY WITH
AGENTS AND BROKERS. AND.
SO THERE IS NO EFFORT TO CHANGE
IT TO SOMETHING ELSE ABSENT THE
AMENDMENT THAT THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED IN THE AUTHOR TOOK SO.
WITH THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD.
.
FARTHER PERSONS HERE WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ARE THERE ANY PERSONS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
AND THEN THERE'S A TWEENER.
FIRST LET'S SEE IF ANYONE IS
HERE TO SPEAK AGAINST IT.
OUTRIGHT.
HUNDRED PERCENT OPPOSITION.
NO BUT WE DO HAVE A TWEENER GO
AHEAD MR HER OUT A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OVER
HER ALL THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE.
WE.
HAVE NO OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL THIS TIME WE ASKED A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS OF THE ARM
SPONSOR.
AND IT THE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
RAISE MORE QUESTIONS.
SO WERE PROCESSING THROUGH THAT.
THERE IS I I MUST BE CANDID
THERE IS A HEALTHY LEVEL OF
SKEPTICISM GIVEN THE HISTORY OF
SOME OF THE PLAYERS THAT IN THIS
AREA BUT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THAT HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE. AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
WOULD SUGGEST AT A BARE MINIMUM
SOME REPORTING LANGUAGE.
SO THAT THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
HERE CAN BE PROPERLY ASSESSED A
AND WE PROVIDED SUMS.
A DRAFT TO SOME SUGGESTED
LANGUAGE TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORED SPONSOR ON THAT.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER PERSON SIR.
IN THE TWEENER CATEGORY.
ALRIGHT OTHER NO OTHER COMMENTS
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
THIS BILL DOES HAVE AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND MISTER COOLEY
HAS AGREED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT.
AND.
IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER COOLEY WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE UP JUST AFFIRM
THAT THIS IS THE BILL I'M NOT
CARRYING A BILL IN ANTICIPATION
OF.
FURTHER CHANGES OR MORPH INTO
SOMETHING ELSE FIT LA ABOUT A
QUESTION I VOTE GOOD THANK YOU
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION.
OTHERS MOTION AND SECOND ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I BIGELOW.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
CALDERON.
CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU.
COOLEY HIGH COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE FRAZIER.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE.
NINE ZERO THAT'S A NINE TO ZERO
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
I DON'T SEE MR LIVE THEME HERE.
ALRIGHT MR LEVIN'S NOT HERE OKAY
WE WE HEAR HE'S SO.
ON ROUTE SIR.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD HER.
SOMEWHERE NEAR THE CAPITAL SO.
.
YEAH PATH.
YEAH.
YEAH I THINK.
WE MAY AT WE HAVE ONE OTHER ITEM
A WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR
MISTER CHAO'S BILL AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FOUR.
ONE ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES MAYES
AYE BIGELOW. CABALLERO PROBABLY
ARROW I CALLED RUN. PENN. CHEN
AYE CHIU.
COOLEY. FAMILY I COOPER ALRIGHT
COOPER AYE FRAZIER.
GIBSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE.
NINE ZERO.
SO REGARDING MR LEVIN'S BILL.
.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
CALENDAR DEADLINE WHERE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT IF WE DON'T
HEAR THAT BILL TODAY.
IS MR LEVINE STAFFER HERE.
YEAH KURT ONE.
THE SCENE OUT THERE ARM YET
TERMINALIA.
HE'D AS YOU SAID IS EN ROUTE.
.
AND TOUGH HOPING I WAS HOPING
THAT WAS HIM BUT.
.
BUT A HELLO MISTER CALDERON.
YOU KNOW INSULTING PEOPLE ISN'T
GONNA GET YOU ANYWHERE OKAY.
COULD RESIST.
SO.
.
I'M CERTAINLY COMFORTABLE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PERCENT BILL IT
HAS AN AYE RECOMMENDATION.
AND.
.
ANYONE OF MAYBE TRY TO.
GET A HOLD OF HIM.
YEAH I WOULD THAT I COULD I.
COULD I ASK A. ANOTHER MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE TO THE
PRESENTATION I'D FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE DOING THAT.
.
OKAY UP. BUT NOT.
MR GRAYSON'S OFFERING TO PRESENT
THE BILL.
THANK.
MR GRACE.
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO GIVE.
GIVE KURT A MOMENT IN THE
SPOTLIGHT THE.
HE OP.
AMATEUR HOURS NOW OVER I DON'T
YEAH.
THE GOOD IN.
IN MISTER GRAYSON YET THERE ARE
PROCEDURES THAT TO HAVE TO BE
FOLLOWED AND I BY PROBABLY LEAP
FROG SOME OF THOSE.
SEIZURES BUT MISTER GRAYSON HAS
SIR. NOBLY OFFERED TO PRESENT
THE BILL GO AHEAD SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF.
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS.
THANKS STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
PARTICIPATING IN SEVERAL
DISCUSSIONS THAT HELP TO ACHIEVE
THIS BALANCE.
OF A VERY BALANCED BILL THAT
LEVINE IS BALANCED
YEAH.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL DOES.
WITH.
WITH THE WITH ME TODAY IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS PAUL
YOGURT REPRESENTING CINEMA
COUNTY AND I DO WANT TO STATE.
THAT.
THAT THE MEMBER WHO JUST ARRIVED
HAS ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
RIGHT.
MR.
SO MISTER LEVINE NOW YOU YOU OWE
MISTER GRAYSON AND Y. WOULD GRAY
DON'T MESS THIS UP NOW IF I
ALREADY KNOW I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
I'M GONNA SAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
AND.
JUST FOR THE RECORD YOU'D YOU
HAVE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS
I HAVE AND I JUST AMAZING
LEGISLATIVE JUJITSU BY YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
TO ADD TO GET TO WHERE WE ARE I.
ON IS JUST THINK ALL OF THESE
HOLDERS BEEN WORKING WITH ALL OF
US ON.
THANK YOU.
.
IF IT'S GONNA GET PSYCHED UP THE
MINUTES GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPARENT OF. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT GO AHEAD MR AROUND ALL
THAT MR GO TO FIRST THINK MISTER
YODER OUR THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PLOY TO SHUDDER AND TO
HAVE THE BOARD TO SEE RESIDENTS
CINEMA. NAPA AND MENDOCINO
COUNTIES GREAT PILLAR DRIVE VOTE
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROBERT
ROLL THAT BECOMES YOUR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE JUST
VERY BRIEFLY. MANY OF THE BILLS
THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN THAT ARE
MOVING IN THE SENATE ARE FOCUSED
ON. HELPING SURVIVORS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE HORRIBLE
TRAGEDY THAT OCCURRED LAST YEAR
OF THIS BILL IT'S LIKE CONTRAST
IS REALLY FOCUSED ON HOW CAN WE
TRY TO MINIMIZE.
INCIDENCES OF UNDER INSURANCE
WHICH IS UP FAR TOO COMMON WHEN
YOU HAVE.
DISASTERS OF THIS MAGNITUDE
PARTICULAR WHEN YOU FACTOR AND
WHAT WE REFER TO AS DEMAND
SEARCH IT IS MORE EXPENSIVE
AFTER A DISASTER OF THIS
MAGNITUDE TO REBUILD. LABOR
COSTS OF MATERIALS ETCETERA
I AND SO THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT THESE
REPLACEMENT COST ESTIMATES
OCCUR.
INET REGULAR FASHION BECAUSE THE
MORE THAT OCCURS
THE SMALLER THE UNDER INSURANCE
GAP GETS
AND SO WE RESPECTFULLY URGE AYE
VOTE IF THOUGHT THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I'M JOINED
BY. JOEL OUT YOU THE CHIEF
DEPUTY THE DEPARTMENT HAS WORKED
ON THESE ISSUES FOR DECADES.
THANK YOU LET SIR INVITE ANY
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
ANY COMMENTS SERVE FROM THE
PUBLIC AGAINST THE BILL.
IF NOT COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
AND AGAIN THIS AS AN I
RECOMMENDATION.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED AT THE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING CARE ACROSS WITH THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN I THINK THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND COMMITTEE STOP
SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR HELP AND
WORK ON THIS BILL.
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING
FORWARD ON ANY IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES AND.
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MICHAEL BOLAN AGAIN WITH
MECHATRONIC WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
IF NOT TO WERE BACK TO THE
AUTHOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER.
AT ALL RESPECT WESTERN AYE VOTE
GOOD GOOD.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS IT HAS AN
AYE RECOMMENDATION ANYTHING ELSE
FOR. MARK ON THIS ONE OKAY WERE
CLEAR. BOTHERS A MOTION AND
SECOND ROLL CALL VOTE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES
AYE BIGELOW.
THE CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON AYE
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HARPER TONIGHT HARPER AYE.
PHONE TWO ZERO TWELVE TO ZERO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
GRATEFUL FOR A FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT FROM YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
YOU BET YOU BET LOOK.
AND.
NOW WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ADD ONS.
TRACY IF YOU COULD.
.
WORK DOWN THE LIST AND WE'LL
GIVE MEMBERS A CHANCE TO VOTE.
OUR LET'S GO WITH CONSENT AB
TWENTY.
THIRTY FOUR.
BIGELOW.
CALDERON.
CALDERON I.
CHIU.
Q. I.
MISTER BIGELOW WE'RE ADDING ON
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THEY ALL I.
FRAZIER OUR FRAZIER AYE THIRTEEN
ZERO.
THEN WITH SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN.
I. MISTER BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE CALDERON. CALDERON
AYE CHU. CHU AYE COOPER BY
COOPER AYE. THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
THEY BE TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR.
HELLO.
BIGELOW AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CHU. CHU AYE
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE THIRTEEN
ZERO.
I THINK EVERYONE'S VOTED MISS
KIRBY ROW ABLE TO ADD ON
EVERYTHING.
GOOD.
WELL THE.
A GOOD AN IMPORTANT BILLS.
.
WE'RE DEALT WITH THIS MORNING
AND ALL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY ON
ONE OF THANK EVERYONE AND.
DO WE HAVE A IS OUR NEXT
MEETING SCHEDULED MARKER WAS
IT'S STILL UP SO YEAH.
YEAH IT WILL DEAL WITH SENATE
BILLS A IN THE MONTH OF JUNE.
SO THANK YOU ALL THE MEETING I
THINK WE GOT EVERYONE VOTED
RIGHT OKAY MEETINGS GERUND